america's bombing campaign has killed
dozens of islamic state fighters in
recent days
and the group's advance into iraqi
kurdistan is at an end
but for many hundreds of thousands
facing a new beginning as refugees
the air strikes may have come too late
when i hear
the plan or the sound of the plan of the
americans i said that's maybe
became safety
25 year old sardar hajibasi was one of a
handful of yazidis to return to his home
near the mosul dam this week
he's the local english teacher and
though while his pupils have long since
fled
he came back he says to look in on
livestock left behind
in a hurry just they taking his family
and leaving
they don't care about anything his cows
and their sheeps
you know all the families that say
that's maybe
the end of the my the village a month
ago this village called bozan was a
thriving community of seven thousand
yezidis today it's like a ghost town as
one villager put it there's around a
hundred men left here
all of them on with kalashnikov rifles
the islamic state
is ten miles down the road and residents
who remain in these villages face a
frightening reality right across this
region
sardar's hometown sits beside christian
settlement al kosh
now almost entirely empty kurdish
peshmerga forces now control the mosul
dam several miles
west but islamic state fighters still
hold positions just to the south
in telsguff this is your protection yes
this is all you have against yes islamic
state nothing else
yes nothing just this is it enough
yes it's enough to save himself enough
but saving the yazidi culture that
survived here hundreds if not thousands
of years
has not until recently been a priority
for iraq's leadership
the government in fact that they don't
help israelians
you do not have anything here among the
yazidis who've abandoned villages like
this
many are asking will they themselves
ever come here again
either